[Musique]
bon
nous vivons dans un monde d'une grande
complexité notre environnement et plein
de subtilité
il renferme une quantité sans fin de
mystère
quel miracle d'être dans ce formidable
univers
[Musique]
oui car a priori ce n'était pas gagné
notre monde aurait très bien pu être
ennuyeux sans art sans poésie et sans
aucun matheux
un néant ou un chaos sans complexité
sans flèche du temps sans aucune
structure apparente
sans conditions sans propriété émergente
tout aurait pu n'être qu'un vide
intersidéral
ou n'être qu'un bruit blanc à entropie
maximale
[Musique]
sauf que non étrangement le monde n'est
pas ainsi
et ça c'est un miracle absolument inouïe
[Musique]
des immenses structures planétaire et
galactique aux structures atomiques
voire même subatomiques des supernova et
aux étoiles à neutrons des quarks gluons
des photons aux électrons en passant par
les formations géologiques les glaciers
les chaînes de montagnes et les volcans
une molécule c'est leurs interactions
chimiques sans oublier la diversité du
vivant
l'incroyable complexité des écosystèmes
et la survie de bestioles en milieu
extrême désert au séquoia défiant la
pesanteur des fourmis capable de poids
spectaculaire au pieuvre dont
l'intelligence en lettres tentaculaire
la sophistication de dame nature laisse
songeur et au beau milieu de ce décor
fabuleux dans une contrée des confins de
notre espace-temps
voilà pour nos sapiens cet animal
merveilleux doué de facultés stupéfiante
de raisonnement homo sapiens est doté
d'un cerveau complexe fait de 100
milliards de neurones dans un cortex
capable de penser des espaces
hyperbolique de concevoir des théories
algorithmique de maîtriser le feu le
vent et le solaire et de contempler sa
propre place dans l'univers homo sapiens
a même complexifier son monde en
construisant des méga civilisation en
développant des circuits de coopération
en communiquant radios micro ondes
il est parvenu à fabriquer des vestes de
l'aisne à produire des macarons et des
mises en scène à établir commerce
international à parcourir le monde et
bientôt le spatial homo sapiens a créé
sophistication qui dépasse désormais son
imagination
[Musique]
notre environnement nous offre un sacré
spectacle
mais
une conséquence importante de ce miracle
c'est que l'univers est du coup
[Musique]
sophistiqués
et qui semble donc impossible de le
résumer si ce n'est en infirmant c'est
compliqué
notre espace-temps est difficile à
expliquer il est des choses que jamais
nous ne comprendrons il ya des
subtilités qui nous échapperons pire ces
subtilités paraissent irréductibles le
monde ne semble pas entièrement
compréhensible
et semblement de douter des conclusions
hâtives de se méfier des punchline trop
affirmative de ne pas glorifier les
répliques destructive et de plus
valorisé l' écoute attentive plutôt que
de croire pleinement des spéculations il
semble qu'il faille souvent admettre
notre ignorance
il semble même qu'il faille admettre que
notre intuition est rarement la
meilleure voie vers la connaissance mais
surtout pour vraiment maîtriser un sujet
l'humain a besoin d'années de
concentration mais même là son savoir ne
sera pas parfait à son ignorance
il doit prêter attention
[Musique]
néanmoins il acquiert ainsi une
expertise qui lui permet souvent de
meilleure prédiction que celle
d'intuition exprimer sans attention
sans cette expertise on dit souvent des
bêtises
l'idéal serait de comprendre la pensée
des experts de vérifier leurs sources et
suivre le raisonnement
toutefois ceci requiert énormément de
temps des décennies d'études sont
parfois nécessaires
cette complexité est souvent
sous-estimée comprendre les avis des
experts
c'est compliqué les alors c'est moi je
n'ai pas leur expertise
il semble judicieux de déférer mon
jugement de croire un avis informé que
eux maîtrisent et même d'accepter qu'il
dépasse mon entendement
au lieu de dépenser mes ressources
cognitives si une confiance en les
experts est justifié il semble utile de
croire leurs paroles prédictive pour
ensuite mieux choisir quelles actions
initiées
[Musique]
alors ceci peut sembler insatisfaisant
comprendre le monde tout entier
à
[Musique]
le truc c'est que le monde est vraiment
compliqué nos cerveaux dont 100
milliards de neurones seulement nous ne
vivons que quelques milliards de seconde
nos ressources en temps et en calcul
sont finies et le nombre de données
sensorielles est trop petit pour
absorber toute la complexité de nos
facultés cognitives sont très limités du
coup il faut l'admettre le monde
c'est
compliqué
[Musique]
ceci peut sembler être une triste
observations manquons d'attention et de
compréhension
toutefois je vois en fait là un second
miracle
ce miracle consiste en l'absence de tout
oracle l'univers est en plus complexes
que nos cerveaux mais aussi plus
complexe que nous calculateur il restera
toujours quelque chose de nouveau
quelque chose à découvrir un sense of
wonder
[Musique]
on ne parviendra jamais à tout expliquer
il nous faudra toujours conclure
c'est compliqué
on pourra toujours étendre le champ du
savoir il persistera des erreurs dans ce
qu'on peut croire on aura toujours de la
marge pour progresser
des questions à poser des angles morts
de la pensée le raison de l'ignorance ne
sera jamais loin des créations seront
toujours à portée de main
[Musique]
les restes aura des phénomènes disséquer
des champs de savoir à davantage
explorer
l'univers renferme des mystères dans
tous ses coins sa complexité garantit
une quête sans fin
et ça c'est le plus grand miracle de
l'univers c'est ce qui rend nos vies si
extra ordinaire